tu programa y comienzo preguntándole por
estas manifestaciones que estaban
programadas para hoy particularmente en
Brasilia esto es un síntoma de que se
está regresando a la normalidad en el
país o se mantiene esa atención en las
calles brasileñas
Hola buenas noches gracias por la
invitación Yo te diría que son un poco
de las dos cosas no después de lo que
hemos tenido el domingo que fue
realmente un día caótico con la invasión
de la plaza de los tres poderes la
invasión del Congreso Nacional la sede
de gobierno la sed de la suprema corte
hasta el día de hoy cerca de mil
cuatrocientos cincuenta personas siguen
encarceladas por la policía federal que
les está tomando tus testimonios con el
objetivo de identificar quién son
Realmente los que están por detrás de la
organización y la financiación de esa
insurrección que hemos tenido el último
domingo como tú has señalado teníamos
previsto para el día de hoy miércoles
una serie de manifestaciones no solo en
Brasilia sino en varias capitales y
todas Con el impacto de lo que ha pasado
el domingo las prisiones y etcétera
canceladas Porque no solo el Gobierno
Federal como los gobiernos de los
estados han reforzado la seguridad y la
inteligencia para evitar nuevos
episodios señor en una reunión
extraordinaria de la Organización de
Estados Americanos Allí se sumaron más
voces en el Continente en rechazo a
estos hechos ocurridos en Brasilia
durante el fin de semana este apoyo
internacional Qué efecto tiene a nivel
local y en respaldo hacia el gobierno
sin duda alguna hay una un apoyo
internacional no a la democracia en
Brasil eso tiene un impacto directo en
el vaciamiento la desmovilización de las
personas de los grupos que están
organizados con este fin yo te señalaría
que por otro lado Eso no significa que
el país volverá Tan pronto a la
normalidad nosotros tenemos un nivel de
polarización muy alto que significa que
casi 50% de los brasileños no aceptan el
gobierno que ha sido investido en el
primer de enero lo que nosotros no
debemos tener
en los próximos días y semanas
seguramente es la repetición de lo que
hemos tenido el último domingo pero la
atención se mantiene la división se
mantiene y luego que el congreso vuelva
a funcionar el 1 de febrero seguramente
Presta atención que vivimos en la
sociedad se va a reverberar dentro del
Congreso que en este momento pues está
de vacaciones señor puntual por favor
este hecho ya es momento para hacer un
poco de análisis de lo que va a
representar para la historia de la
Democracia brasileña esto sienta un
precedente o deja en evidencia que esta
polarización que usted menciona puede
erosionar muy fácilmente la democracia
brasileña cómo lo vio usted
Bueno yo veo que va a ser muy decisiva
el papel que va a jugar el presidente
Lula no el presidente Lula dijo durante
la campaña que iba a ser un gobierno de
conciliación que el país necesitaría de
unificación si ese si esa determinación
sale de La retórica y va a la práctica
posiblemente Tendremos una normalidad en
los próximos meses ahora dentro del
mismo partido del presidente hay grupos
muy radicales que no admiten ningún tipo
de perdón a los que invadieron el
domingo las instituciones y los que han
estado por detrás O sea no la va a jugar
un papel decisivo en todo eso